-John, here's how it works.
This button is the Random
Travolta Generator.
We'll each take turns
hitting it,
to select the name of a role
made famous by you,
John Travolta.
-Alright.
-We'll perform a small part
from that movie or show
the best we can,
and at the end,
we'll decide once and for all
who is the better
John Travolta --
me...or you, John Travolta.
[ Laughter ]
So I will go first.
I'll show you how the game --
here we go.
[ Beeping ]
[ Audience ohhs ]
Tony Manero from
"Saturday Night Fever," okay.
I can do this.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
It just feels so weird doing it
right next to you.
It's okay.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Clears throat ]
[ As Tony ] You know, I work
on my hair a long time.
[ Laughter ]
And you hit it.
He hits my hair.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That was pretty good.
-It's really good.
-He hits my h-- he hits it.
-I don't know
if I can beat that.
-Ah, you can beat that.
Yeah, alright, John,
you can go next. Here.
-Alright, here we go.
-That's the generator there.
[ Beeping ]
We give it a minute there.
-Yep.
-Yeah!
[ Audience cheering ]
-[ Laughing as Danny Zuko ]
[ Laughter ]
Well, that's cool, baby.
I mean...
[ Audience cheering ]
You know how it is,
rockin' and rollin' and whatnot.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Audience cheering ]
Ah, he's the best!
Alright.
Let me start the Random
Travolta Generator.
Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
That was unbelievable.
[ Audience ohhs ]
-Whoa.
-Oh, yeah,
this is a different Travolta.
Okay, I know this one.
[As Vincent Vega]
You know what they call
a quarter-pounder
with cheese in Paris?
They got the metric system,
so they wouldn't know
what a quarter-pounder is.
They call it
a royale with cheese.
Is that right?
[ Cheering ]
Alright, alright,
you're up, you're up.
[ Beeping ]
Castor Troy. "Face/Off."
Castor Troy.
Now, you're the bad guy.
-That's the...
-That's the -- Yeah.
-Alright.
-So you're John Travolta
playing Nic Cage.
-Okay.
-This is a tricky --
This is a tricky --
-Ooohhh-whee, you good-lookin'!
You're hot.
[As Nicolas Cage] It's like
looking into a mirror
only not.
-Wow!
[ Cheering ]
How do you do that?!
How do you do that?! Yes!
Alright, John,
for this last round,
why don't we do this one
together, okay?
-Which is it?
-Let's try it and see.
[ Beeping ]
[ Audience ohhs ]
-"Welcome Back, Kotter."
-Vinnie Barbarino!
-Okay.
-"Welcome Back, Kotter."
Here we go. Alright.
-[ Clears throat ]
[As Vinnie Barbarino]
Hey, Mr. Kotter.
-[As Vinnie Barbarino] Hey, why
don't you take a couple days off
and go hang gliding?
This is good weather for it.
No wind.
[ Laughter ]
-What? Where?
Up your nose with a rubber hose.
-Off my case, toilet face.
Want to do the funny dance?
-[ Normal voice ]
Let's do the dance. Ready?
And here we go.
Together: ♪ I said-a
Bah-Bah-Bah, Bah-Barbarino ♪
♪ Bah-Bah-Bah, Bah-Barbarino ♪
♪ You got me
rockin' and a-rollin' ♪
[ Singing indistinctly ]
[ Audience cheering ]
-♪ You got me
rockin and a-rollin' ♪
♪ Hoppin' and [indistinct],
Barbarino ♪
♪ Oh, you got me rockin',
whoo! ♪
♪ You got me reelin', ooh! ♪
♪ You got me ooooh ♪
Together:
♪ Barbarino, yeah, yeah ♪
[ Audience cheering ]
-The winner! It is official!
John Travolta is the best
John Travolta there is!
-Like in "Pulp Fiction,"
I grew up with all these
kind of novelty dances.
So, in "Grease,"
there were coming --
They needed a step for that
"You're the One That I Want"
at the end.
So I said, "Well,
we used to do the four corners.
Why don't we do that?"
And then the choreographer said,
"Well, show it to me."
And I did and --
-What is the --
Can you show it to me?
-Sure. Come on.
Let's do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-My gosh.
This is unbelievable!
Alright. Alright.
What do I do?
-Ready?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What do I do?
-Wait until it gets
into a good groove.
-Alright. Alright.
So what do I do?
-Right, left, back, back.
Right, left, back, back.
-You guys! John Travolta!
-I love the new look,
by the way.
-Like it?
-Yeah, I love the clean cut.
-Yeah, this is Pitbull-inspired.
-[ Laughs ] Is that right?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Well, I just saw the video
you just did.
Pitbull's -- I don't know
if you saw the video.
Well, you must have.
Like 10 million people
have seen it on YouTube,
but it's called "3 to Tango."
Have you seen this video?
And you think that it's Pitbull
the whole time.
-Yes, and then I surprise them
at the end
and I dance the tango.
-You do the tango, yeah.
-Yes, yes.
-How'd you meet up with Pitbull?
-I reached out to him
three years ago,
and he's a great entrepreneur.
He'd come up with these
good ideas to work together,
and this was one of them.
-He's a genius.
-Oh, he's awesome.
-He makes hits like -- it's like
he wakes up in the morning
and he's like, "Ah, guess
I'm gonna make another hit."
-Yeah.
-He's a very positive person.
-Last time you were here, uh,
I was lucky enough to learn
a dance move from you --
the four corners from "Grease."
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And thank you, but...
I was wondering, today,
could you teach me --
speaking of the tango
with Pitbull --
could you teach me how to tango?
-Absolutely.
-You will?
-Come on.
-I don't know how to tango.
Alright, what do I do?
-Come on this side.
'Cause I'm used
to leading on this side.
-I love it.
-Alright, so...
With your left, my right...
-Yeah.
-...we go step, right,
and then I want you to kick out
but put your head back
at the same time.
-Okay.
-There you go.
So, ready, and...
Step, kick, boom.
-Oh, sorry, sorry.
Let's do it again.
-Okay, and...
-Step, kick, boom.
-And then if I turned you
around like this...
And then we did salsa...
-This is how --
That's how you do it.
This is the guy right here
you want to hang out with.
John Travolta!